le département vous présente terre de
trail toutes les courses du grand raid
passe par ce spot une des portes de
mafate bien connue des pique niqueurs
pour saboter un équilibre fragile que
florent souhaite préserver
[Musique]
alors aux commandes de sa tranquille
alors coup de fil à tvo l'impôt qui
permet menzah d'accueil d'accord alors
montage au ballon laurent boyer
il travailla le n9 assistant technique à
l'atelier bois
en fait c'était déjà une passion
la forêt la montagne comme fait du trail
et où donc est venue naturellement
[Musique]
alors ce site mais c'est vrai que c'est
un cas fois pour autant pendant le
congrès de la mascareignes et ben nous
on essaye d'aménager au maximum les
aires d'accueil
le n9 l'atelier ont fait des mobiliers
bois en bois pays
on a un ternois neuf fois équipé pour
les collectivités aient tous les aires
de pique nique permettre d'accueillir
environ 5 millions de personnes par an
c'est le coureur les suiveurs la famille
les amis
il faut que tout le monde
tout le monde tout le monde est dans la
l'événement - dans la course mais il
faut que tout le monde s'y est ce le
site dé 100 anciens étape avec
l'événement grand raid on est déjà on
est avec l'association grand raid sur 27
ans que en partenariat avec le nfc avec
le département et nous en tant que
agents nf
on est fiers on est
quand on passe les sentiers même quand
on sait que tous et toutes ces personnes
ont passé des sentiers ouf on entretient
et que on entretien au quotidien toute
l'année et la savoie que l'événement
passe sur les sentiers entretenu par la
neige c'est un réel plaisir
c'est énorme en fait parce que vous
occupez du bonheur des ravitailleurs là
après ou des saucisses une siesta
égrillard non ouais ouais ouais ben là
ne siffle maximum pour que les gens n'en
profites tu penses à pourquoi quand vous
travaillez tu penses que tu fais c'est
pour nous fait ça pour tout le monde pas
pour tout le monde et puis s'il est fait
piéger à john est bien au top mécontents
change rien c'est chouette devant des
jeunes qui s'occupe de notre île de la
nature nous retrouve les bonbonnes
course à tous mais aussi bonne route à
eau merci à l'est
[Musique]
le département vous a présenté terre de
travail